Distractions, uncertainty, poor visibility, miscommunication, and working under pressure:...
...These are the conditions that can set the stage for a runway incursion.
Prevention is everyone's responsibility.
Pilots, air traffic controllers, flight service specialists,...
...and vehicle operators should use common sense,...
...and follow some basic safety procedures.
Avoid distractions in the cockpit while taxiing,...
...like running through checklists or engaging in unnecessary conversation.
Remember: a safe flight is from gate to gate.
Be particularly vigilant at night or in poor visibility.
Look out for other traffic, and watch carefully for airport signage.
Become familiar with airport layout and taxiway designations.
Make this a part of your pre-flight preparations.
Report faded or missing signage and markings to ground control.
Listen carefully for instructions over the radio and read-back all hold-short instructions.
Avoid ambiguous communications,...
...and make sure the person you're speaking to understands what you've said.
Don't be afraid to ask for help or a repeat if you're not sure.
Delays happen - be patient, and keep a cool head.
If you think a pilot or vehicle operator is lost or unsure of their position,...